Today, we will reach the unconscionable, tragic
milestone of 100000 dead Americans from Corona
virus.
That is a number we may have already reached
by the time you listen to today's show or
watch today's program.
And that is a number that we have reached
with wide spread.
Now, allegations of data suppression in a
number of different states, which I will discuss
with you on tomorrow's program.
But we've already passed.
One hundred thousand is the point whether
we officially get there today or yesterday
or tomorrow.
We actually have passed that number sometime
ago due to the belief that suppression and
a mischaracterization of some deaths.
And as this is going on, the president of
the United States has been tweeting allegations
that a TV host murdered someone without any
evidence.
And Donald Trump also tweeted or retweeted
a tweet calling Hillary Clinton a skank.
But today, I want to talk about these murder
smears that Donald Trump has been making against
MSNBC.
Joe Scarborough.
Donald Trump tweeting, quote, A lot of interest
in this story about psycho Joe Scarborough.
So a young marathon runner just happened to
faint in his office, hit her head on his desk
and die.
I would think that there is a lot more to
this story than that.
An affair.
What about the so-called Investigator Reid
story?
Trump also tweeted a blow to her head body
found under his desk left Congress suddenly.
Big topic of discussion in Florida.
And he's a nut job with bad ratings.
Keep digging.
Use forensic geniuses.
So what this all relates to is Ace Joe Scarborough's
staffer that died in 2001 was a 28 year old
woman, Laurie cla- Soudas.
And conspiracy theories started about her
death pretty quickly down in Florida.
And this is 19 years ago.
Trump is now reviving this and giving it oxygen
media me merely because he is in a media battle
with Joe Scarborough, because he doesn't like
Joe Scarborough's coverage of Donald Trump
on MSNBC.
That's all that this is.
But the president is accusing a media host
he does not like of murder.
Even many Republicans are disgusted by this.
Illinois Republican Rep. Adam Kinzinger tweeted,
quote, completely unfounded conspiracy.
Just stop.
Stop spreading it.
Stop creating paranoia.
It will destroy us.
Fox News bomb thrower Brit HUME even tweeting,
quote, 30000 retweets for this discredited
tale based on a three year old post from some
wingding Web site.
This is why even his critics should want Trump
to play a lot of golf, because when he does,
he's not tweeting crap like this.
So the analysis here is 90 percent obvious.
And I want to focus on the 10 percent that
maybe is less obvious, of course, in that
90 percent.
Yes.
This is not normal.
The world is laughing and crying and pitying
us.
Yes.
Trump accusing people of murder on Twitter
is an absolute and total horror as one hundred
thousand people have died of Corona virus
in the United States, with as many as two
thirds of those deaths preventable with just
a couple week earlier call for national stay
at home orders.
The only remaining question is why Trump is
still allowed on Twitter.
And I got a lot of e-mails over the weekend
from from you guys saying, David, you know,
Trump is he's specifically targeting someone
with false allegations, with a conspiracy
theory.
That person, Joe Scarborough, is being bullied
now.
Joe Scarborough is getting death threats.
And how is this how is Twitter allowing this?
What you have to understand is Twitter has
very specific rules for what you can and can't
say, but they have different rules for famous
people and politicians.
And Twitter put out rules last year, I believe
it was, which I'm characterizing it in the
way I see it.
You can read the full text of it if you want.
If a world leader or a politician tweet something
that would normally violate their policy,
like, for example, in this case, Trump is
targeting an individual for mass bullying
like Trump did by saying Joe Scarborough might
have murdered someone if it's Trump, if they
leave it up, because the mere fact that it's
Trump who said it makes it newsworthy in a
way where it's newsworthiness and the fact
that it will be reported on necessitates leaving
it up so that it can be properly reported
on is sort of the gist to it.
And I understand that.
But Twitter can also say make the news elsewhere.
Right.
It's not what we want our community to be
used for making news about.
Imagine being.
The family of twenty then 28 year old Laurie
cla- Soudas, you've been trying to recover
from an inconceivably traumatic event that
took place 19 years ago where your 28 year
old family member died and incomes the president
of the United States re-tweeting a three year
old conspiracy article from a non-sense Web
site.
All because he doesn't like Joe Scarborough's
coverage of him.
This is an era.
Listen, the Trump era is going to be an era
where no one.
We should never forgive the Trump administration
nor the people who voted to put him in power.
But as a country, hopefully at some point
we fix this atrocity.
Hopefully it's in five months.
It might not be until four years and five
months, which would be tragic.
I hope eventually the world is able to forget
the United States as a country.
I'm not saying forgive the Trump voters, and
I'm certainly not saying forgive Trump and
his administration.
But I hope I hope that at some point the world
will forgive us as a country for this absolute
aberration that hopefully will only last for
years, but may last eight years if we don't
take care of business on November 3rd.